it is a very special night for us as I
said it's true if you count all the
shows we did in New York and all the
shows out here
this marks our 4000 episode so that's
kind of yes it's nice nice nice little
nice little landmark nicest kind of cool
thing yeah it is and I actually I have a
surprise for you I I put together a
montage of the very best moments from
all of those 4,000 shows did you you
really did that yeah yeah I mean it's
cuz it's a you know it's a landmark so
let's wait you went to it all the talk
about 25 years yeah yeah let's let's
look back rolls it's crazy this is great
once dr. Phil gets out here it's going
on
you've got perverts in the front row
they're down here to get some titty that
is that well I mean it is a six pound
difference yeah
is it laxative and a hoverboard really a
good llamo get dressed in romaine one
Wow
it's so many memories so many members
right
just it's great they just just seems
like those were all highlights of you
were they yeah
and it kind of seems like they were all
just from the last two weeks yeah I
didn't really have a lot of time
well congratulations happy four thousand
thank you Andy
you
you